OK guys, in my pocket I have
some Broken Lizard trivia
questions.
Whoever answers these questions
correctly is going to walk
on part in the next movie.
Exciting, right?
OK, here we go.
Shitface, you're first.
The first question is a
"Super Troopers" question.
Have you seen "Super Troopers?"
-Oh yeah.
All right, you're
going to great.
You're going to do great.
All right, Shitface,
between Kevin and Steve,
which of us would
you rather [bleep]?
[laughter]
Don't shout out the answer.
Which of us would
you rather [bleep]?
Shitface?
I want a mustache ride.
I'm going with this
guy right here.
There you go.
I feel a little
hurt by that, but--
By the way, Shitface,
that answer is correct.
One nothing Shitface.
All right, Sugar
Tits, you're up buddy.
Your question is a
"Beerfest" question.
Have you seen "Beerfest"?
-Absolutely.
You're going to do great man.
You're going to do great.
Sugar Tits, between Kevin
and Steve, which of us
would you let [bleep] you?
It's a little different.
Which of us would
you let [bleep] you?
Sugar Tits, before you
answer this question,
I would just like
to say to all of you
that this game was way
better with chicks.
[laughter]
Good game with chicks.
A lot of fun with girls.
Very good game with chicks.
OK, but we make do.
OK, Sugar Tits,
what's it going to be.
Steve.
Oh, [bleep] yeah.
What the [bleep]
is going on here?
I think he's afraid
of falling in love.